constate que les manuels mâcon se
victimise à chaque fois qu'on pose une
question sur son programme ou sur le
financement de sa campagne
on a des questions qui sont légitimes
bon il n'a pas souhaité y répondre
quand il y répond on voit que il ya
quand même des sujets sur sur le
financement par une partie très très
aisé 1,2 de la population de sa campagne
électorale
bon ensuite sur la question de l'unedic
par exemple l'étatisation de l'assurance
chômage qui propose c'est donc mais
totalement de côté les partenaires
sociaux c'est une vision très très
auto-centrée très très centralisé du
pouvoir il a une conception finalement
extrêmement classique presque
monarchique de la vème république
c'est vraiment le contraire de ce que
propose benoît hamon et ce à quoi moi
personnellement j'aspire mais en même
temps
l'ennemi numéro 1 c'est le front
national est jeune est important de le
préciser vous nous dites votre ennemi
numéro 1 votre ennemi principal non mais
les rangs
je refuse l'argument qui consiste à dire
pour voter utile dès le premier tour
puisque certains agitent cette menace du
front national dès le premier tour non
soyons clairs il n'y a pas de menace
pour national au premier tour et donc le
seul vote utile c'est le vote selon ses
convictions parce que c'est très
important y compris pour ensuite définir
quelle sera la lame les égéries pour
emmanuel macron pour éviter un
un deuxième tour françois fillon
c'est une gigantesque hypocrisie ça ça
serait éventuellement françois fillon
est quand même très bas il est à 17 ou
quelque chose comme ça dans les sondages
on voit qu'il a des grandes difficultés
dans sa campagne dont